північ добре запускає 24 роки на дубі
додому true максимально то rtm pro 9 ранку
зради
два місяці турклуб cipro володів і
своїми не фабрику за вбивство в суть
всіх для виточування деталь виду зброї
Артем розуміється на трави мирних моделях
вин розрубавши кріплення до автомата
калашнікова хлопці та сцен можете купити
три молоді та
і всі асети тепер можна прочитати те
наші кріплення держак до того ж ми
випускаємо про decker кому дефекації у
даному на жаль тортури за розробникам модифікацію
перед вільні гранатомет в ір сіна та для
будь-який тирил а ви ключ на для ризикових
зброї тут на висновок є алла вас тут
видного оснащення в науково настріляти та
ми просто їх зарастро базі брат і
загорнуті тій поїдуть до хлопці за кілька
кілометрі злетить на уколи тікеєво
склад волонтер його розмазати туди якщо
плані для калашникова і до та склепінням
продадуть на фронт люди приносять сюди та
і ще допомогу раз побачи акорди на
тур вона сумкою сапоги теплу білизну
соломи бронежилети
по kong і з'їжджу це медикаментами шкірок
третій день усиновить возять нас хіт
волонтери скажіть з міністерство воякам
часто продають наякі з не ричі і
cyber-shot ходять між допомагає сам
цьому українці там і за кордон не
до допомагати груші мам обоє за вас почитай
армію тим чим не змогла держава почуття
дуже багато дуже багато пожартувала що
просити про рівний це що я розумію
батутах тобто вже заглянув тобто
гріна пурана на їх то свою я можемо чого
снилося.
ми отримуємо загрозу ми реально всі у
адже брахманом ага йому серця давати ls
слава богу треба в нас накида і люду до
допомагати
люди допомагають люди які обирають і груші
для армії та бази та до їх булу папірець
віри ти купер мову